[relaxed surf music]
♪ ♪
- Hut.
Hit it, hit it.
Give me the ball now.
Hike it, yes.
- All right,
come on.
- I'm open.
- Oh, shit.
Oh.
- Don't you think that
was a little out of line?
- Cool it, roach.
Don't you know who this is?
It's Adam DeVine
from "Workaholics."
You know, Boy "Broad City."
- That's right.
- I don't care.
- Game's over, kids.
Can't take up this much
beach real estate.
Hey!
Hey, hey!
Shaka, bros.
- Okay, how come
we're here out here
trying to play real sports
and you let surfers walk--
do whatever they want?
- Half my business
is surfers, okay?
And these dudes just flew
in because there is
a massive tropical
storm headed this way.
- God, surfers are so sexy.
- Tell us more
about this tropical storm.
- It's called
the 100 year wave.
[dramatic music]
- Why do they call it that?
- 'Cause it comes
every 100 years.
- Oh, yeah,
that makes sense. Yeah.
- Oh, yeah, I heard that
on Surfline.
That's crazy.
- [surfer accent] Yeah,
and actually I heard that too,
on my landline.
Someone called me
and told me about
what was happening
on Surfline,
so I also
know what's up.
- Adam, do you even surf?
- Obviously I surf.
You can tell by the voice.
Do I even surf?
- Hey, I need you
to get back to work. Please?
- Bye, surfer boy.
- Looks like Daddy's
got to learn how to surf.
I'm calling myself "Daddy" now
and I don't want that
to be weird for you guys.
[surf rock music]
- Those waves look
pretty big, Adam.
I think we should probably
take surfing lessons first.
- Matt...
we learn from our mistakes.
Remember that.
Whoo!
[grunts]
[groans]
[exhales]
[high-pitched]
Lesson learned.
[theme music plays]